citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to continue our Brooklyn nine nine
Journey episode 14 of season five Greg
how you doing how you feeling fine John
good fine leave a like for being fine
subscribe if you're feeling three out of
five and uh join the patreon if you want
to see the full length reactions of
these episodes watch along with us a lot
of fun let's do this thing
um
what the hell is going on
setting up an interrogation
oh Sterling K Brown
I'm Phillip Davidson detective Jake Paul
to ask me to drop off Ben just too
murdered someone I think he did it can
you show him to interrogation room C
please have fun in there thank you and
he does have excellent teeth how
uncomfortable this guy is jacked up the
thermostat got the table all sticky made
one of the chair legs too short and
worst of all I had Gina greet him what
did you however do be yourself of course
son of a yeah Kevin and I are
attending the Opera oh the Opera is it
the one Bugs Bunny sings yes so who's
this this is Philip Davidson the Opera
tonight irrigation for the ticketing
clock and everything on the line
I better call Kevin and tell him I won't
be attending the Opera there's someone
else I'd rather hear saying oh
and I won't be joining your driver
tonight uh
[Laughter]
it's gonna be a bottle episode all in
one room
with no subplots
you're right he did it
but we have no murder way you really
didn't find any usable forensic evidence
the body was discovered rotting in the
shoot up by Coyotes the only other DNA
other than the vix was some bear semen
found in the hair Ryan who found the
body you're really gonna just blow past
the bear seam in detail I imagine a bear
mistook the rotting corpse for a female
of its species and had intercourse with
it nothing happens yeah
I've been there Geraldo do you know what
I miss most about being a detective a
good interrogation breaking suspects
down talking quietly and then talking
real loud a lot of these techniques do
work better with two people you know
good cop bad cop Crazy Cop saying cop
fast talking StreetWise cop in Hong Kong
cop AKA The Rush Hour you know what
let's do this let's break this up Rush
Hour Rush Hour this
this is Captain Raymond Holt he's a bit
of a legend in interrogation circles Hey
cap who's the scariest person you've
ever gotten a confession out of Connie
buttons okay thought it was going to
sound a little cooler but no matter
the night that Robert Tepper was
murdered you were the last person to see
him alive correct no I'd imagine whoever
killed him some after I did oh nice
Dodge
so cool he could teleport around the
ring most people thought it was
impossible to get past him I beat him
every time you just punch him when he
gets dizzy really I mean duh
genus and anesthesiologist had gone home
and Grace Who usually locks up and left
early because her grandson had a school
play so it was just you and Robert
Robert just wanted to talk about firing
one of our office assistants show and
that's all you discuss yeah yeah would
you like to hear what he said the
meeting was about
7 P.M talk missing meds
uh yeah how'd you know that I think
that's hardly sounds like firing Cheryl
so maybe you want to but how do you know
what his calendar said
I'd like to move on unless you have any
other big revelations in here let's see
if I'm Gomez you're Morticia I feel so
happy when I'm with you yeah
bars
Partners but it was Robert's name on the
business correct he started the practice
and then I joined after something's come
up in the case can I talk to you on time
for a sec totally undermined me I
apologize but he's dancing I'll Badger
him with my Superior intellect while
simultaneously belittling you once
Philip dismisses you as a threat I'll
leave you alone with him and he'll let
his guard I would say you're describing
smart cop dumb cop look I thought you
had him on the counter yeah that's the
rush hour yeah so Chris Tucker would be
smart this time so what do you want me
to do ask stupid questions stupid
questions grammatical errors lose your
train of thought just ask them to
confess relate everything back to those
movies you've seen kind of seems like a
shot at me about die hard but okay oh me
want to dumb cop I got that yeah well
done it's gonna be like a play with
Robert in the surgical Suite one at your
office I was just preparing for the next
day's surgery so you have an assistant
who does that I'm a meticulous person
careful how I do things so careful that
you I'm sorry I forgot what I was gonna
say
it had undergone industrial
sterilization to remove all traces of
blood it's surgical Suite people
bleeding there every day we have to
sanitize it by law I remember what I was
going to ask
I said yes I would have had you
I went to a bar the Scotchman I didn't
want to drive drunk so I took a cab you
didn't have your phone I left the
charging in my office and I didn't
realize till I was already out of the
building oh man if I go 10 wow oh if I
had it on me you could have seen a
pinging off the cell tower it doesn't
matter didn't have it on me so you took
a cab
he is taking such advantage of knowing
he's not caught don't you think maybe we
should just wait till your boss comes
back oh you'd like that wouldn't you
because you're scared you know I'm
playing Hardball except for that the
balls are questions
and did you kill him and what did your
cab driver look like this seems like a
huge waste of time Robert drove a sob
Dana's head was blind and sterilized on
Wednesdays and Saturdays I haven't been
to burning in 20 years oh man kill him
and the cab driver had a beard in the
earring I'm sorry I didn't get his
license number
this guy seems like a master manipulator
you didn't fall for my did you kill him
Gambit no although it is interesting you
knew the body was found in Vernon New
York when that information hasn't been
released to the public
hey hey hey yeah
Dolly
nice way to pick up on the details I was
the dumb cop I mean I've watched planet
Earth with the British narrator
[Music]
actually Robert's wife told me I've been
talking with her a lot comforting her we
asked her not to share that info this is
everything with his slick smile yeah my
uncle has a cabin there I would visit
him as a kid so your uncle owns a cabin
in the town that the body was found I
haven't been there for 20 years you can
call my uncle if you want so you might
as well just confess now or we can take
our sweet time the Majestic sleuth
we don't have them but I just told him
we did have him Phillip's uncle said he
hasn't been to the cabin in months and
he hasn't spoken to Philip in over a
year damn it God damn it but if he
hasn't been in months Philip doesn't
know that he's rattled right now if we
tell him the neighbor saw him that
put his feet up for you to stand behind
me and say like three oh damns when I
really get cooking all right fine two o
dams one odam there will be no there
will be no dams at the very end
uh you're guessing what happened that
night but what if Philip never went to
the cabin he did I can feel it here my
gut your gut or intestines is lower you
should Point down here closer to your
pubis I'm guessing yes if Mad Dog
Peralta will do that who knows what else
he's capable of you don't get angry well
what that's not true remember how angry
I got about how fast Daenerys got from
Dragonstone to north of the wall
true that some of those are scary count
chocula much all right fine I see your
point what do you suggest let's get all
up in the personal space make them feel
uncomfortable okay fine let's get
intimate
yeah Sam it's been like four hours three
hours three hours what was on Fallon
highlights what was he doing slow jam in
the news who was the guess
you got some old silver fillings in
there you probably want to drill those
out replace them with porcelain okay
close some serious plaque buildup let's
get back to it no no open-minded let me
see oh
not only did we not break them but now I
have to go to the dentist
Dental talk is giving me an idea
okay 11 16. it's funny when people call
dentist Doctor we are doctors we do four
years of medical school it's called
dental school but we learned about the
entire body but if you had cancer you
can call it dentist you know it's
actually harder to get in the dental
school than medical school oh my God you
are Riley him up most people want to
become actual doc that's ridiculous it's
not like we're College professors
calling ourselves doctors not the same
thing my friend sure it is medical
practitioners have co-opted the word
okay Captain I know we live in a world
where anything can mean anything and
nobody even cares about at the moment
I thought it was a good tactic yeah I
know I thought I was gonna break them
his middle name's Henry Robert Henry
Tucker his wife called him Rob work that
in robbed up work it into full name
Robert Rob Henry tough
now trying not to Blink so tears come
into your eyes
man this guy is a good murderer there's
gonna be some way to break him wait a
minute
two three four he brought the guitar
back
wow yeah I really gotta stop trying that
it never works I almost worked on Kid
Cudi he always tries it on the black
people I know Skip the Opera has
anything to do with him not believing in
you oh my God that's good why do you
make you dumb cop he didn't make me dumb
cop not if it's any of your business oh
no why wasn't he done complete you never
would have bought this that um between
the two of us you were more believable
as uh them yes dumb uh the the number of
twos kick his ass
kill your captain
pretty sure it was you honestly it could
have been any one of our employees they
all have access to the storage room you
know it's silly but uh I trust the
people who work for me yeah because I
want him here really are you in charge
and all those strategies you've been
coming after me with those were all your
ideas guitar thing was mine and you
signed off
and you're gonna spend the rest of your
life in prison everyone who loves you
will leave and you will die alone and at
that time it will be your head that a
bear has sex with oh yeah
yeah
take him serious angry but if my body
just seems like when a muppet gets upset
the Stars growing like oh you want angry
I'll show you angry oh God this guy has
just really gotten under my skin I'm
gonna go to the bathroom and try and
clear my head I think that's a good idea
good
it out oh he's gonna walk in the
interrogation room yeah what are you
doing guess what
your uncle's neighbor saw you go into
the cabin tonight but my uncle only has
one neighbor and I'm pretty sure he
didn't identify me because he's been
dead three years I'm friends with Steph
Curry
you dumbass oh you were lying in an
attempt to frame my client no no no no
no look even if we who knows you screwed
up and my client's leaving he can't
leave until I dismiss him you've had him
for 10 hours and 45 minutes then I'll
just keep him for 14 minutes seriously
just to be childish are you doing
it's not about everyone okay
ABC stuff
to make it quick you only got eight
minutes all right then let me paint you
a picture I'm Phillip a successful
periodontist that's become addicted to
diazepam a sedative I take because I'm
junkies where are we going no one day
I'm working late when my boss Robert
surprises me he found out I was stealing
meds again Chucky's gone also again not
your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's
going to file a police report
a lot about this Peralta Yelp shot has
six of these heavy Looking Glass awards
from the Brooklyn periodontics Society
in the background this shot only has
five what happened to number six
murdered Robert with him you lost all
control oh dang you were in the surgical
Suite it can be sterilized you never
would have gotten away with it in your
carpeted office and your office manager
would have heard all of the screaming
but she was at her grandson's play lucky
again you're wrong you put Robert's body
oh Escape he's breaking I believe what
you've done you're flustered he has a
place there you're the luckiest son yes
it was you got lucky at every turn no I
knew exactly where I was driving yeah
yeah you can use some glass of water if
you idiot but clearly see what's missing
I made a ride out of a special dental
polymer yes it's already in a patient's
mouth son
oh damn
oh damn oh damn there it is 30 dams
all three you had the wrong murder
weapon talking to you I realized what
Philip's worst fear actually was that we
would think he was just some dummy that
got lucky he had planned the perfect
crime and it killed him when you said he
was sloppy and impulsive he needed us to
know how smart he was yeah Kevin
[Laughter]
thank you sir let's go get some sleep
hey guys
my goodness we're almost late for work
well well in that case good morning sir
good morning bro oh what a sweet scene
with that crane shot
all right team you know I I think we
should just talk about this one okay I
know we've been doing two a week but I'm
making an executive decision here oh
you're Captain halting me right now yeah
yeah dumbass okay let's just review the
episode yeah let me get my guitar that
was very special yeah that was a
terrific and I kind of feel like I don't
know if the next one is gonna compliment
it completely this seems like a very
Standalone episode yeah this feels
exceptionally Standalone it just doesn't
feel right to start again I love how
they actually got Sterling K Brown for
this yeah and and and he was like it
feels like it was written for him I I
wonder how this episode came to be
because absolutely I mean it's very much
you're not like famous enough to have
something written for like if you're
like that famous but he might know some
people involved where they did like or
people who are fans of his work and
they're like yeah we we customize it
because he was two perfect yeah it was
obnoxiously perfect yeah yeah and and a
real character a real character and and
plus you know no subplots or anything is
just the three of them pretty much
except for the lawyer the entire time so
like yeah this feels like some kind of
event episode or something even though I
I I'm fascinated yeah to if you guys
know comment below because he he was
just such Perfect Chemistry with the two
of them and the game across the board
was just so much fun to watch and to
watch him like you know really get to uh
play a character obviously but like it
just seemed like he was able to have the
most fun like really settling in and
just feeling himself and and you know
riding that wave you know yeah uh that
was an absolute Delight of an episode
yes I I feel like this is like an S tier
b99 like this is like a top it's very
special this is this is it was like
halfway through I'm like this is one of
my favorite episodes 100 yeah because it
it never sacrificed comedy the comedy
would come unexpectedly it seemed like
the interior
sometimes the Dr if they're doing like
an actual genre heavy episode The Comedy
is still comes front and center and then
the the
subsidiary genre is the thing that is uh
you know it's not like an afterthought
or a second thought it's just not the
main it's not the main focus where here
it actually felt like that was the main
focus yeah yeah and then the comedy
would come naturally because the Rhythm
was like so much like a play that I was
finding myself even impressed with Andy
Samberg especially Andy Samberg this
time yeah because
you know sometimes on network TV you
kind of learn your lines a day before or
something like that but I'm like this
must have taken some serious rehearsal
yeah no they were so synced up and and
everybody played their role in the
frustrations so yeah and they say you
can't handle the tooth which I thought
was interesting because I was like well
this sort of feels like an Aaron's
working play yeah 100 yeah totally and
and that's I like I wonder yeah what
what the construction of that was in
form not just around Sterling K brown
but whether they wanted to like
specifically be like oh we haven't done
like an actual bottle episode or
something or if there were like
complications of like oh we can only
keep like some of the cast isn't
available it still gets to him in a way
of how Tom Cruise gets the jacket
yeah yeah well that's the smart like
that's the smart dumb thing is is yeah
you know people and and you know Killers
certainly serial killers they say like
yeah you want to be recognized for your
Ingenuity and uh and yeah it's like it's
all character based it's all about
luring and drawing drawing out and
probing at the characters and for so
much of it you're watching is yeah he
gets under their skin until they finally
figure it out and even that the timing
of that him going in and grabbing the
pictures really quick I was like okay
this could go in a cute Direction where
it's just like oh magically I figured it
out but I even bought the resolution by
the end that sort of stroke of of wisdom
of of sort of inspiration of it being
yeah not just you know creating a
different sort of FIB with the award but
realizing oh yeah yeah yeah like the
thing that we've been having so much
friction over is you know being made to
look dumb or or feeling like yeah we are
you know sloppier than we actually are
and using that against him was just like
a really clever thing to do and it was
one of those things where where you know
the the comedy it just felt like a
complete
blend like a really natural blend of a
game that we want to see cracked you
know it's like it's really easy to pull
you in with that
um and then also slip in the comedy and
really fun and interesting ways but that
always has like an intensity and a
momentum about it yeah I I really I
really loved I like I think Sterling K
Brown you've kind of a
just epic performance here because he he
he's all about
the is all about everything he
it's like this Debonair quality you know
that he has to always put up at this
like always keep himself composed no
matter what it's like I said we're going
10 hours into the middle of the night
and he's got to be the guy who has his
together and there's such a
Cockiness to him yeah they're so cocky
there's a whole time like the entire
time when he's being interrogated he's
got this smile of just yeah you guys
know I did it I know I did it but I can
outwit you the entire time
it all comes down to evidence and
technicalities and all these things so
you just plain and simple I'm just I'm
too smart for you guys yeah and and so
he's just having fun he is taunting the
whole time uh it's really clever and you
know and it is he can't show when he's
being worn down at all but but I love
how they would give like these little
hints and these little misleads like I
was so into it when you're like okay
this is gonna be the thing that gets him
to get him to confessed when when Holt
is going I mean like Andre bro fantastic
again like to me this is like I imagine
I imagine Andrea comes from like theater
so sure
I don't know what his acting background
is he strikes me as a theater performer
um
but yeah like that moment when he's
digging at him with his uh yeah dentist
not being legit I thought it was a
tactic you know and this and I think the
show wants you to think it's a tactic in
that moment yes
he was just actually upset yeah and it's
also the perfect foreshadowing exactly
it has to be regarded he has to be
revered you know it has to be respected
and it supports uh Peralta's Revelation
that much more in a way that is
completely not obvious and if it's
character based for all three of them
yeah yeah all three of them it was
really character based and surprisingly
nuanced and
sometimes when they are doing something
that has more in its mind than the
comedy
it sometimes the comedy can feel forced
this really did feel like a natural gel
all around yeah totally no no like 100
this it felt like the most natural thing
like somehow I like the the writing the
Performing the circumstances everything
just felt So Graceful and it's like yeah
I was never missing jokes but when they
would show up they would catch me by
surprise the moments of intensity were
actually kind of intense and it shot
really well yeah they have some like
great lighting
um great Shadows uh the consistency with
the interrogation room a lot like the
way they would do the framing if it was
like a close-up on Peralta and you would
constantly have Holt in the mirror being
reflected watching him the entire time
and you'd constantly have Sterling K
Brown in the background like doing
little yeah even if he was like way in
the back yeah you can always see him
doing something and it's always
something in contrast from being rattled
or whatever it is and two I think it's
paced really nicely because obviously
it's only like 20 minutes but it still
feels like you were there there all
night in a way that's not a detriment or
not like oh what a drag but like yeah I
feel like it does when they're finally
out in the dawn light you're like oh
yeah like you have that sort of
catharsis a little bit of like when you
you know did something for that many
hours on end and finally succeeded and
now you can kind of rest yeah yeah and
then that last moment with them was just
so sweet and and felt really off the
cuff somehow like that thing where he
says Kevin you know as being like the
person who's got to prove how smart he
is and they both laugh almost felt like
an improv or something like just the way
you get to snorkel after Halt and like
the way their voice is cracked like I
don't know there's just it just felt
like a real sense of camaraderie behind
and in front of the camera or I guess in
life but also in context of the scene
just go to work though they worked
massive overtime I think they can get I
think they would be like hey we so we
cracked we got someone okay yeah we
gotta murder confession yeah can
somebody yeah there's got to be a way
for Holt to take a day in Pearl to take
a day you don't want somebody who just
pulled an all-nighter investigating more
crimes
I mean I guess it would be easier for
Hulk because he just has to do office
things but
damn I I feel like no one's ever talked
about Sterling K Brown's performance I
had we had no idea did you have any idea
who's gonna be this did you read a
description beforehand no I didn't
really I had no idea and the thumbnails
on this season for Amazon are just the
yellow Brooklyn Nine-Nine logos yeah I
had no idea he was on the show yeah I
had no clue he was on the show yeah
um so and now I'm like but I'm only this
is like a performance that I feel like
people would talk about like like his
appearance here yeah I'm trying to think
where this would have been in his what
year this would have been and where that
was in the rise of Sterling K Brown
because certainly in the past handful of
years he's been catapulted to much more
sort of like household name status
because he knows how to make ego and
narcissism very Charming he does I mean
this reminds me the hard thing to do
this reminded me of a better version and
a more grounded version of that
character he played in The Predator
movie where like you know he's just like
Mr cool but here it's tempered in the
right way where it's not just like oh no
one's directing you you're just doing
your thing and having fun yeah and I
mean he's good in that movie too but uh
but yeah I don't know it's just so
lovely which is a fun time to be
watching this this woke me up I've had a
I didn't sleep guys at all right we had
the Loki trailer this morning I'm
shooting this
and when I say I didn't sleep I really
didn't I was I was fostering cats and um
you had to interrogate there's one cat
who was like five cats and there was one
cat who's still learning how to use the
bathroom properly and uh didn't notice
that the blank because I was
I didn't notice it peed on my blanket
and I didn't know it's like three in the
morning and I was like well I can't
leave this spot where I'm at because
I want to make sure they feel safe right
now yeah so I'm just gonna try to lay
here even though
and then uh it was one of those nights
where I was just like laying down with
my eyes closed but I never actually fell
asleep oh sure yeah yeah I reached six
in the morning in the Loki Church
yeah I'm very I'm very well it was very
sorry before we shot this I'm like wow
this woke me up that was great that was
really good yeah that's powerful I'm
feeling what they're feeling yeah yeah
well time to go back into work
well guys leave us your thoughts on the
episode what did you think is it one of
the best of all time
I mean like I think there's an argument
to be made for like well maybe the best
episode has more of the Ensemble but
this is absolutely suck screw all those
people care what are even their names
Gina Jim Boyle oh you're getting them
right
um Rosa that girl from Encanto yeah
Alfred Hitchcock the woman on that
Blockbuster show older and Scully and
uh that America's Got Talent host yeah
um America's got a Canon Nick Cannon
America's gotten again well guys what's
your favorite v99 episode and why is it
this one comment below and we'll catch
you next week
it's another two for peacock
[Music]